the Denver Broncos are in the mix
they're in the hunt at five and six once
upon a time they were three and six and
if you're wondering what happened to go
from three and six to five and six it's
because Emanuel Sanders spent his bye
week on NFL gameday morning and he joins
us now live from Denver Colorado to kick
off our number two with that did I put
my finger on it
Emanuel you Debbie put your finger on it
I want to thank you guys for help
helping us turn the season around Thank
You Network thank you rich eyes thank
you guys
you're welcome as I said you know with
all humility I say you're welcome to
that outside of that what has happened
over the last couple of weeks Emanuel
like we're clicking I feel like we're
playing as a team you know the defense
and create turnovers the office been
able to take advantage of those
turnovers that were planted as a unit or
plan for each other and we're starting
to find out how we can win games so you
know obviously the two teams we played
they said we got Aleksey wins because
you know the Philip Rivers turn the ball
over and turn the ball over but that's a
rebate those esterday plays to get out
of stadium but it W so you know we're
optimistic that we can keep that going
as well because we got a Cincinnati feel
like we can go out and handle business
against the world
so before we continue down that road and
I know you've got your own locker room
to deal with you you were expert at
being part of the paparazzi with us on
gameday morning so if you wouldn't mind
pict putting your analyst hat on just
for a brief bit here also knowing the
Steelers organization as well as you do
and Big Ben as well as you do and
Antonio Brown as well as you do I mean
Big Ben was was definitely vocal and how
Antonio Brown drifted in the end zone on
that final interception he also called
out Washington for dropping a ball or
not running through it and diving at
even said that they should have thrown
it to juju Smith's Shuster four straight
times on the final drive as opposed to
what the plays were calling how do you
think that's all sitting in the locker
room there yeah I was in our locker room
that wouldn't sit well be because that's
a situation that I feel like you handled
in-house instead of talking about it you
know obviously he's a leader
gee you know he's a quarterback on our
team and everybody looked at him -
totally
and so in doing that and going to the
medians saying those things you know I I
definitely probably pull them to the
side and be like hey man if you have a
problem with anything I don't want to
feel it I would rather you talk to me in
person about it didn't you know talk
talk about it in a radio because there's
ways to avoid that obviously he's right
his emotions are probably running high
after the lost intercepts and all that
stuff you know something just keep it
out and then knows that and so you know
that's what I would did if I was in that
situation well again I I know you have
your own situation you might not have
heard at the end of that radio interview
he said that he has earned the right to
criticize after all these years would
you agree has a right to criticize
you'll have the right to go on a radio
and just call guys out because if
somebody went on a radio in knowing Ben
and somebody went on a radio and then
called him out you know throwing an
interception or doing this or or taking
us tackle you supposed to throw the ball
away more than likely you probably come
with a lock home like hey man like like
why did you do that you know and so I
think it's just all about being a good
teammate and like I said I play with
being and I know how Ben Ben is and even
you know talking to him you know been
some times 'listen emotions get to get
the most of them especially out their
loss and each can't do that you know and
that's just speaking truly of just what
out is you know in terms of handling
guys I'm not I don't I don't I don't
like throwing guys under the bus
especially to the media even though the
media loves it well what did what how
did you find a Antonio Brown if you
chatted with him before the game after
the game I mean did you spend any time
with him your old team yeah yeah yeah I
saw him prior to the game we should
shake hands you know at the 50-yard line
just caught up for like 10 seconds they
went too much we were both worn out but
it was definitely good to see him and
like I said that's a Hall of Fame player
man you know made a lot of plays what if
this first news organization continued
to make a lot of plays and so on that
okay and so and while
you've got your paparazzi hat on and
again like I told you on the set and I
said on the air you've got you've got
the chops to do this once you're done
you want to stop playing football what
did you and maybe some of your teammates
think of Baker Mayfield extending the
arm and not given the the the bro hug to
Hugh Jackson and then when asked why was
actually point-blank honest about it
from the podium ever watch the film on
Baker Mayfield daisies he's a good
quarterback
I enjoy really watch these guys
Cincinnati and they played against mr.
daddy man and that's expensive flair and
the Browns are lucky to have a man but
you know Baker uh you know I understand
kinda sort of his emotions but in
understanding how this goes you got to
understand it you know if you had to do
what's best for him and it's family as
well this is the NFL you know at the end
of the day this guy had these job yes he
has a family you gotta take care of you
gotta take care of himself
you don't want to sit out and not make
any money so he had to make the best
decision for himself and and sometimes
in this league that's the nature of the
business you have to make the best
decisions for you when when a team let
you go or a team doesn't want to pay you
and so that's the nature of the business
this is in college football is it's not
one of those situations I feel like even
though Baker obviously you know he knows
that now and and if he doesn't you know
that's that's just my opinion of that of
the National Football League and so you
know coaches go to different teams just
like players go to different teams you
know we happened with us when the Mary's
went to the Texas they would play the
best same week I would tell them yeah I
was telling everybody ok you think the
Bears go over there like no I'm not
gonna let you guys go to Broncos two
minutes drill their plays in their
signals and of course you're gonna do
that because he had to do his best in
himself I'm going play for the Texas and
he's trying to win a game and so that's
the nature of the NFL yeah Manuel
Sanders you're gonna see Baker Mayfield
in the Browns in your house a week 15
Saturday a game that looms it's looking
bigger and bigger with each passing week
right now I mean and so to me
immanuel it seems case kingdoms and more
of a rhythm than all year long that he
looks like that quarterback we saw on a
magic carpet ride with Minnesota last
year over the last couple of weeks how
would you assess that yeah that'll be
finding his own and I'm happy for
because I know all the early hours him
getting here and all the late night
study and all the study and he does he's
finally starting to get a grasp of the
offense and grass with his playmakers
and what our strengths is and what a
weaknesses is and Bill Musgrave more
coming together and creating some good
game plans i watch the game and i told
my wife she was going to sit man that
play looks good and that playlist good
which is running great plays get guys
opening and and then Phillip Lindsay and
I running back in there and a ball and a
toad and a line in which nobody really
wanted to give credit to thought we were
gonna be banged up and I can't be as
good man they're holding strong we got
off of the line full of tackles and one
sinner day that that's a guard but you
know they're making it work in a given
case of opportunity to you know pocket
that's wide open an opportunity to get
rid of her boy he's doing that and this
kid Phillip Lindsey's a revelation man
it seems like not only is he just hit in
the hole and dominating but he's hitting
people after he's running for 10 15 20
yards and then he's barking he's
whooping he's whooping after every play
well what's going on with this kid I
mean I love it I love it a lot of people
made it knowing his personality I mean
Phillip he's from he is a native of
Colorado and he still stays in his
parents basement okay I tell him all the
time man you a superstar man he didn't
even know he's a superstar Beezus oops
sorry just welcome playful boy expansion
everybody
he believes in a seller he's confident
he wants the ball he wants to make those
plays and when he makes those plays he's
gonna let you know he he's coming back
for more and so I like to play with guys
like that because I play with guys on
the ladder that didn't want the ball but
that's confident and so you know the
have you been bringing that energy to
our offense man it's definitely it's
definitely good for hunter why it's fun
to be a part of and uh you know
hopefully continues to do that because
this domain he's gonna be he's gonna be
a special flare washer I knew that he
was
real deal Emanuel when when Terrell
Davis said short take my number 30
I mean that back that meant something
and now he's didn't Amaya so Luke so let
you know right there Danny
he kind of gets in terms of being a true
blocker like I say the Colorado native
is is he the only player you've ever
played with Emanuel you're in your ninth
season now is he the only player you
played with who lives in his parents
basement
yeah that's the first time I heard that
and when I heard I said people are gonna
run crazy with that usually I said
you're about to be a legend today like
didn't even get what I was saying but I
said man you got to be a legend once
everybody finds out that you still live
in your parents basement and playing in
the NFL so yeah I actually saw so much
Instagram where people are starting to
get hold up it's pretty funny it's
pretty cool so Vaughn doesn't have an
extra room in that mansion with his club
and everything he just never did yeah
yeah because that I think it he wants to
be he wants to be a defense base he is
crushing it he really is you are about a
hundred days shy for 30 second birthday
do you know how many players in the NFL
right now this year over the age of 30
level 800 receiving yards do you know
how many there are over the age of 30
over 800 receiving yards guess the
number more that's it it is you know
just you know it's me Wow a b-29 he's
not yet the big three Oh bud Wow I love
it I love it yeah how - what do you
oldest there's resilient this is one
that one to go out and make plays and
want to go out and chase great that's
what I'm chasing every day I wake up and
I tell myself chase my goals and chase
my dreams
it feels good to be healthy in this
position and making those plays doing it
you know still at a high level at my age
though you know I still feel young so I
mean hearing that man that feels good to
know well actually Antonio is 30 it's
over the age of 30
anybody who's 31 or older
you're the you're the only member of
that Club right now I love it I love it
let's keep it going let's get to a
thousand now alright man alright look it
was great senior at the NFL Network and
and hopefully we'll get you back I mean
are you guys are you openly talking
playoffs in that locker room right now
it's on one game at a time now you know
you know having spent time with a
microphone on your lapel like me that
the one game at a time response is not
acceptable it is now you know at the end
of the day we see the schedule we see
what's going on we see that we could
potentially go ten and six but at the
same time it's not gonna bad it will
handle business this weekend so you know
I gotta keep these guys focus on the
goal at hand okay
very well done Emmanuel let's chat down
the line okay sound good
you gotta that's Emmanuel Sanders the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience